- You named him Gus,
but it's August right?
- It's August, yes.
- So was there something
about the month of August?
Is that why you?
- August is when we found out
that we were having a boy.
And yeah, it's also the month
that my husband was born.
So we just, and we love the name Gus.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah 'cause my husband's
last name is Goldsmith
and I like being an alliterative name.
Mandy Moore.
And we wanted to have a Gigi.
- Yeah, Kelly Clarkson, River Rose.
- Right?
- Yeah. My kids are like that.
I like alliteration, yeah.
- It's fun, yeah, so easy.
- [Kelly] It's great for monogramming.
- Yeah.
- It's also nice for that.
No, but what's the hardest part you think
that you didn't see coming?
Like being a mama?
There's probably a lot.
- I mean, I don't even know
where to begin, all of it.
It is every cliche in the book, right?
For those parents out there,
like life went from sepia
to technicolor like that.
I mean it's just the most overwhelming,
all consuming love.
And it's funny 'cause
I've been playing a mom
on a television show for
six years and I'm like,
wait, can we go back to the beginning now?
'Cause I know what it's like to be a mom.
I've been faking it.
- I am so method right now.
- Totally.
- In it.
Was that hard though, to play a mom
like, not being a mom.
]Cause I did hear, Milo outed
you a bit whenever he was here
'cause he said I had to teach her
how to do her first diaper.
- [Mandy] Oh yeah.
- [Kelly] Like change a,
and you didn't know how
to do it 'cause you didn't
have a kid.
- I, yeah.
And I just, my husband
and I, neither of us
really had any experience with babies.
- [Kelly] Me neither before I had one.
- So I just remember having
to lean on Milo so hard,
especially in the beginning of the show.
- Which Milo doesn't have children.
- [Mandy] He doesn't have children
but he has nieces and nephews.
- I have nieces and nephews and I still
had never changed a
diaper before my children.
- Milo's just...
- That's your baby's butt,
take care of your own.
I was like, I didn't make anybody do mine.
- He was showing me how to
swaddle, how to change diapers.
- He's so good at that, okay.
- He was incredible.
And even, this was like the first season.
And then I remember
right before I gave birth
to Gus last year, same thing.
It was like we were shooting
a scene where we had to
like, change and I'm like,
I'm about to do this in real life
and I have no idea what I'm doing.